ordinary readers the people who read the
paper who simply want guidance about
what they might come to see what might
interest them I think of what I do is a
critic is translating specialist
knowledge into generalist language so
that ordinary people can understand it I
don't write for performers although I
know that they read it I don't write for
other specialists although I know that
they read it I write for for folks
that's actually the way that I put it
just as i wrote my armstrong book and
away from my mother if you do that with
integrity in seriousness then you will
ride in a way that will speak to more
than just folks that will will be of
interest to a very wide range of people
but first of all I think you have to
reach the general audience you have to
write in a clear straightforward if
possible exciting language that will
make sense to them
the most important thing blogging does
is give your readers immediate access to
you either through comments if you have
them on your blog or through the email
channel of the blog which is always
faster than any other way that somebody
can get in touch with you I try to
answer my mail I'm interested in it i'm
interested in getting to know the people
who write to me through blogging I got
to know other bloggers some of whom have
become friends in real time so to speak
I don't know that blogging has changed
my writing because I started blogging
when I was in my late 40s and I was
pretty well fully formed and I the thing
that I think blogging does for many
people which is make their writing style
more natural sounding more speech like
was something that I had always worked
on from the beginning anyway I always
wanted my writing to sound the way I
talked so blogging simply allowed me to
polish this but it was pretty much where
I was already and I was fastenal to I
mean another thing the blogging will
give you if you don't have it is
facility but because I've been working
as a deadline journalist for a long time
if you're not facile you're not going to
get anywhere in that business for me
blogging has mostly been an opportunity
to react more immediately to experiences
to try out ideas that I may end up using
in the print media or in some other
place and when I write books it's a way
for me to bring readers into the
experience of writing the book all
through the process of writing the books
that i right I talk about what I'm up to
on the blog I let people know what I'm
doing you can call that a form of
publicity if you want but I don't really
think of it that way it to me it's just
a it's just part of putting my
professional life up in a way that
people who are interested in it can
access and learning things from them as
well
no there are certain kinds of criticism
that are being made obsolete by these
technologies regional newspapers
increasingly are not employing TV
critics they're not employing people who
are writing about something that that
the whole world has access to and that
they can also get very good copy from
wire services or somewhere else there
will always be a place for well to take
my particular line of work for a theater
critic because that's something that
that you can't get off the wires in New
York is people providing intelligent
coverage of what your theater company
and PO dog is up to and I don't in any
way feel threatened by amateur criticism
the truth is that I think it's healthy I
think it's a very important thing
because amateur of course the root word
of that is love and many of the people
who write what we call amateur criticism
are professionals in everything other
than name and receiving a paycheck very
often they know more than the
professional critic who might be writing
for their local newspaper so really I'm
all for it it's it's changing the
playing field it's shaking things up in
the short run it's going to be
frightening and threatening to a lot of
people but I can't help but think that
that in fact it's going to make the
critical environment a healthier
environment and I'm also especially
interested in what I call practitioner
criticism which is when people who
practice an art forms start writing
about it on blogs I think that's an
immensely important development I want
to see much much more of that people who
make music who are verbally articulate
and not all musicians are verbally
articulate but those who are should be
encouraged to write about what they do
and their perception of what other
people do it makes the discourse smarter